if I could give people a takeaway to
start with that's really simple it
doesn't mean there isn't a lot of hard
work at the other end of it it would be
be very clear on what it is that you
want spend 5 minutes sitting down and
visualizing those things being true and
then give gratitude for that that would
be my first step like see it feel it in
your body taste it in your mouth hear it
in your ears completely immerse yourself
in that 5 minutes longer if you can and
then just be so grateful for all of that
essentially what you're doing is moving
your brain from a fair state to a trust
State and that is the gateway to making
these changes hey it's EV Carmichael and
I make these videos because I want to
wake up and feel like today is going to
matter that I can do something special
and the way that I get that feeling is I
see people who are doing amazing things
and watching them say amazing things and
do amazing things it makes me feel like
I can do amazing things too so I hope
that this video helps you feel like you
can do something amazing today as well
so today let's learn how to visualize
for success
enjoy do you think we have to go through
an identity shift in order to see money
differently and to be able to receive it
differently I think you do absolutely
that's a really great way to go at it so
what was your you know the key words
around your identity with money when you
didn't have much versus the key words
that you would speak about within
yourself or what money is once you
started to unlock more money well it
wasn't necessarily around identity my
words because I did have two very
serious mantras um but there was a lot
of visualizing myself with money and
like I I wrote about buying the Audi and
you are bad and like I'm not the kind of
person who drives an Audi are you
kidding me like and like almost feeling
like this the guy who get like test
drove it with me be like get out of here
I know who you are you can't afford this
exactly so um so but my mantras really
like and before I started make money I
said I can't afford it to pretty much
anything you could throw at me my first
words out of my mouth were I can't
afford it we are buying into an identity
as somebody who can't afford stuff we
are also proving it you know what you
speak you want to prove because you want
to be right and it is sort of the
foundation of your reality so when I say
I can't afford it a hundred times a day
I'm subconsciously pulling in proof like
look at the car I'm driving I'm living
in an alley like I make this much money
a year I'm I'm building all the
foundation blocks to prove that I can't
afford it and that becomes my reality
and then that becomes my I like to call
it familiarity Zone because Comfort
zones are not comfortable interesting
right so so then I'm just proving it
over and over and over and that becomes
my reality when I was 26 I had a man
that sat down with me and he said why
don't you change the way you're
living it never entered my mind that I
could and looking
back and thinking about I think there's
all kinds of people wandering the planet
there's all kinds of athletes that are
not getting the results they want and
they don't know they can change them
right only one person can change there's
only one person in the whole universe
that can change Bob and that's Bob yeah
there's only one person can change dve
and that's Dave now we get inspired by
other people we get helped from other
people but we've got to do it oursel and
he gave me Think and Grow Rich and he
said if you do exactly what I tell you
you can give anything you want well I
didn't believe that
but he was so adamant about I believed
he believed it and
so I started to listen to
him and I set a goal I wanted some money
I wanted
$25,000 now this was in 1961 so it was
more money than it is today but I didn't
even know anyone with $225,000 he said
listen write it on a card keep reading
the book keep doing what I tell you so I
started to hear people talking about
earning money and uh
there was one guy said there's good
money cleaning floors he said you should
clean floors well I wasn't proud I'd
clean floors and he said but you should
do it for yourself not for somebody else
so he told me where I could buy a Ed
floor machine some buckets and mops but
I had to borrow $1,000 well I was at the
point where nobody wanted to touch me
with money and I often say I wouldn't
have lend it to me because I wouldn't
pay it back not that I didn't want to I
just
couldn't but I found a guy and he lent
me the
$1,000 when you when you bought me CU I
have a question cuz I know you when you
borrowed that thousand cuz you owed
people money already you explained that
to people you know you were just finding
yourself but did you have a different
feeling about when you borrowed this
thousand that quite possibly you were
actually going to be able to to to pay
this back this time you know something
if I hadn't had that feeling I wouldn't
have got the money I got it from a guy I
knew his name Al Kyper he was running
and I didn't know him he had a Trust
Company it was like a bank on Dan Fourth
Avenue in Toronto and I went in I read a
book where it says go to One bank if
thing we give you go to another one well
I ended up sitting in his office and he
said what do you want this money for
son and I told him I was going to build
a cleaning company it was going to be
big I had a dream
and I had to explain it all to him he
said I think you'll do it I'm going to
lend you the
money Faith but I knew when I was doing
this I had a picture I had a dream you
see y and
within a year I was earning
$175,000 a year I had my billing up to
$155,000 a month working for myself in
less than 5 years we were working in
Toronto Montreal Boston Cleveland
Atlanta and London England I had my own
company off opening offices all over the
place also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there so many times in life because of
this thing right this this phone that's
all of our pockets um we are so
connected to everything everything is in
the moment right people can text you and
email you and call you it's it's so in
your face that I think it's the busiest
we've ever been and our brains don't
even have time to set goals in the way
we used to because we're just trying to
get through the day like some of us are
like I just want to make it through the
night your head hits the pillow you're
like oh I made it out alive I got
another day right it's hard it's got
this it's like a dust cloud around us
and we're we're expected to set goals
when we can't even see 2 feet in front
of
us so I like to do it a little
differently and this is how I set my
compelling future let's call it a
compelling future not just goals for the
next 12 months let's talk about our
compelling
future I like to pretend it's one year
from
today and instead of us looking through
the dust cloud stay with me a minute I
know this might sound a little hokey but
instead of looking through the dust
cloud of what could
happen let's pretend it's a year from
now and we're looking
backwards and let's pretend it was the
best year of your
life what would have to happen in your
life for it to be the best year of your
life in your career or your income or
your business or your relationships or
love or health or joy and I don't want
you to your brain's going to go oh I
would love for this happen no no no I
want you to trick your brain I want you
to focus it and live it positive Focus
as if it already happened take a moment
and really visualize we have the
opportunity to pretend it's a year from
now and we're looking backwards yeah I
wrote the book you could even uh sue you
said my book is written great your book
is done take it one step further my book
is done and there's people all over the
world with my book in their
hands and they're reading it and they're
on chapter six and they get that story I
never told anybody except when I wrote
in this book and god it feels good when
they hit me up on social media and tell
me about chapter 6 The More We visualize
the more we have a positive focus on it
the more it's not just this dream it's
our reality that we just haven't got to
yet when we can when we can see it in
our
head eventually we could hold it and see
it because it's
real so I'd love for you to shift this
whole goal process thing and turn it
into a compelling future and put
yourself in that spot the reason why
visualization and picturing yourself
succeeding and allowing yourself to feel
the happiness and the pride that comes
with picturing a positive future the
reason why that's is important is let's
say Shelly does that every single day
this week every day she wakes up she
walks for 5 minutes and as she's walking
on that treadmill she's visualizing
herself finishing a 10K in 6 months and
how proud she is every time she does
that she is changing what's going on up
here this isn't something I made up this
is true and it's not only true based on
science but let's think about this from
a common sense perspective if Shelly
wakes up or if you wake up every single
morning and instead of thinking about
the worst case instead of looking at
your body in the mirror and going I'm so
fat I'm so out of shape I'll never run a
10 okay is never going to happen why
didn't I exercise last year I hate my
flabby stomach I hate my my big thighs I
hate how oute I'm embarrassed to go like
if that's what you're
thinking then that is what you're
allowing your brain to continue to
filter the world through if you start
teaching yourself the skill of
visualizing a positive outcome and
feeling the pride that comes with
achieving that positive goal what
happens for you right now now is you
start to think like the kind of person
that does a
10K if after an entire week what Shelly
does is she get looks in the mirror and
she goes I'm getting stronger every day
I'm really proud of myself even though
I'm I'm feeling flabby I'm not saying
you're flabby Shelly but even though I'm
feeling flabby I'm doing the work I can
do this what happens a week from now is
when she sees a registration for a
10K the old mind that wasn't programmed
correctly would go oh you're fat you're
out of shape you're not prepared for
that don't sign up but the new
mind because she's been visualizing
every single day the new mind just seven
to 10 days later is going to go oh wait
a minute I'm in shape I'm proud I'm
doing this why do you sign up it's going
to filter the world in a very different
way because you're training it to this
is the heart of doing a mindset reset
and this is why visualization works and
why it's an important step and why I'm
so glad you're doing it the fact that we
are repeating the same patterns in many
cases of our parents or even of our own
lives from the time R know 20 30 40 50
60 well what if you can go to the Future
and you can think about if I could
change my story today that would get me
to the Future that I want what would the
story
say and in the book I've given you some
excises and some EXC exercises to start
writing out your story now you may think
what do you mean write out my story I
learned many years ago to write out my
money story my life story my
relationship story and I've always
started um in this fashion I'm so happy
and grateful for the fact that I am
living the life of my dreams and I am
traveling all over the world uh first
class and I um I'm able to give to the
Charities that my wife and I and
children love and I'm able to and I
write down in present tense everything
that I'm doing feeling experiencing for
health wealth relationships career
business finances fun experiences
charity I write down a page or two pages
that is a story that I want my future to
be like and then I type it out because I
usually write by hand I type it out and
then I laminate it then I'll record it
and then I'll listen to it over and over
and over again now you may think that
sounds silly why would you do that why
because any information that you get in
through the senses through your ears
through your eyes that you touch that
you feel activates neurons in the brain
when those neurons are activated and
they wire together if you repeat it
often enough your brain says hey you're
investing a lot of time and energy on
this stuff uh let me start to put some
automatic processes to make that story
real and this is where winning from the
inside out comes to play this is why
using meditation and visualization and
mindfulness and affirmations and
emotional man emotional management
techniques and subliminal programming
all work if you can get the information
into the brain and you have spaced
repetition backed with
emotion you are going to develop the
neural patterns that will activate
something called
automaticity all right or automaticity
is when these neurons activate
automatically and then your perspective
changes your beliefs start to change
your behavior starts to change the
filters by which you see the world and
the lens by which you see the world
start to match up with the story one of
the first things we do in our win the
game of money program is we help people
program a new money story so they can
then earn the money they want and live
the life of their dreams why because it
works
visualization
um I don't know when it started I don't
have a tremendous amount of memory uh
some of you know before high school and
and Middle School um my accident when I
was 19 years old really scrambled my
brains so I like some of you can
remember a lot in high school and middle
school and Elementary I'm one of those
people tremendous trouble accessing a
lot of that and just from a brain injury
and so I I don't remember where it
started but I do
remember uh at that
time somewhere in there
I would just lay in bed and visualize
things I'd see
things I I I'd think about going to
school that
day and I would visualize things that
would happen at school sometimes just
fictional things you know here I am
walking up to that girl I like we're
having a great conversation we're making
out at my locker never happened don't
worry but you know they not all visual
I'm not the Law of Attraction guy
because I would have made out with all
the girls in high school didn't happen
just letting you know law of attra
action screw you didn't work you got to
actually talk to people anyway uh I
think that I developed this capacity to
visualize and see things and some of are
make believe stories and some of them
were just imagining how a situation
would
go and to this day including this
morning when I wake up I lay in bed and
I just kind of see what was maybe
already playing out if it was a dream I
just try to visualize and see what's
happening there or soon as I become
conscious and I start thinking about the
day I imagine the day I imagine what's
what's on the docket for today I don't
look at my calendar I don't look at my
phone I just oh yeah I see something and
I imagine it going really
well and so as I see it and I imagine it
going well I also see it going
terrible and how I would deal with with
it right so today uh I did not visualize
this situation I had this morning I
actually visualized some travel I have
travel later on this afternoon and so I
was thinking okay I have to travel
today I I want to have a calm energy as
I pack because usually I'm packing 90
miles an hour and I'm all frenetic
getting out of the house I don't want to
do
that uh okay I'm gonna be on that gon be
a car ride today so I'm seeing myself on
the car I'm talking to some people all
right you know I'm going to call some
family and friends today and the car
ride over to the airport and I just I'm
visualized or sometimes it's not you
know the dream or the day it's I've been
stewing on a big goal or dream something
big upcoming maybe it's a huge Stadium
speech or maybe I'm G to talk with this
particular you know influencer in the
world who I want to have a positive
impact with and I'll visualize that
going well and not well
it's like if I was visualizing a
marathon I would visualize all the
training up to it I'd visualize that
first starting kickoff point I'd
visualize mile 12 when my legs feel like
they're going to fall off I'd visualize
watching people pass me and how I would
feel about that and what I would tell
myself in a positive way to keep running
I would visualize myself then finally
hitting the Finish Line celebrating with
it going out that night doing the ice
bath and waking up the next day feeling
fulfilled the whole life cycle of
visualization is a habit for me changed
my life don't visualize the wi visualize
the whole life cycle of the
activity
pre during post that's what most people
Miss in their visualizations most people
don't actually visualize they think
about something
briefly visualization is taking the time
to think about an activity a goal or a
dream and walking it through in your
mind beginning to end not just the
celebrations and good stuff the hard
stuff what you'll tell yourself to
survive to thrive to keep going on some
of some people
often hear the term visualization and
they think that's not me I don't
visualize and it's like I don't care if
you see it or not I wish we had a
different name for it we call it
imagination
it's a mental process of thinking
through an activity goal or
dream pre during and post the whole life
cycle all I want you to do don't worry
about if you can see everything
perfectly like learn to teach yourself
to see things more
visually but don't think that is a
component or requirement of
visualization let's just step back from
it has to be insanely visual because
people it's not very visual for me
that's fine I want I want you to think
through it let your brain do what it
does whatever think through it means to
you I'm using the same language for
visualization whoever is more confident
wins the reason why that conversation
goes your way is because you believe in
love more than they believe in hate
there you
go as strong as their belief in hate is
or negativity or whatever this as strong
as their belief is you just believe in
love and hope more yes and when you're
around people who believe in the thing
more you gravitate towards them so you
will pull them they will not pull you
down you will pull them up may not
happen right away it may be a process it
may take a week a month a year 10 years
but you will pull them up they won't
pull you down because whoever is more
confident in the thing wins that's how
you're able to pull them out the sense
of being an outsider is also something
that I have
had throughout my
life and uh the sense
of not belonging
here
uh watching my
parents being
engaged in
continuous
conflict not because they were bad
people they were they did what they did
and they loved me as best they could and
they did what they
did as a reflection of their state of
consciousness at that time which was a
normal State of Consciousness egoic
State of
Consciousness but I sometimes felt how
did I get
here somehow didn't there must have been
a
mistake
um
it's often
Outsiders
uh is being feeling an outsider on the
one hand is seems a terrible limitation
that you can't
participate as much on the other hand
it's a great opportunity
because some of the uh most creative
people uh in the world have have been
Outsiders they did not
in uh Misfits it's the English word
Misfits
um now that's the friendships I had when
I was a
child and that's another interesting
thing I had
a friend one of my friends was had was
severely
physically
disabled and nobody else wanted to be
friends with him because of that and he
was probably my closest friend and the
other one was so weird that nobody
wanted to talk to
him uh but he became my friend so they
were Outsiders
too and
uh but the interesting fact here as you
know I couldn't believe it when they
told me
that there are people here from 70
countries it seems almost unbelievable
but that's true I saw the
list 70
countries and you may find I'm sure you
will
find quite
often uh you you you can feel a bond or
you have you have more in
common with many of the people who are
here then you have with your own people
in your own country at home who are not
going through any Spiritual
Awakening who are still totally
conditioned 100% conditioned by their
culture so you feel a connectedness here
with other humans that transcends
culture and conditioning and all the
silly political stuff it transcends that
and this is a wonderful thing so to some
extent and you can now connect with
people even if you don't always see them
physically you might live I don't know
whether you live in a big city or small
village a small City small City small
City yeah yeah what city uh inbrook in
Austria oh yes yeah nice very
nice uh I don't know how many people in
insbrook are
120,000 and how many of those are
Awakening we don't
know we don't know of course but this
helps I believe being here and feeling
you are not
alone you are
connected so this should be a help for
the rest you just have to accept that
this is how it is and no matter how hard
you try to fit in on the normal level
you probably won't nor do you have to MH
so I know this there are many people
here who feel that and be happy with it
but don't make it into some kind of
superiority because the ego can always
creep
in before you know it there's always a
back door and then the ego is back in so
you can you could go from feeling bad
about being an outsider to suddenly
feeling okay I'm an outsider because I'm
superior and then so have to be careful
don't go there so um that's just how it
is if you you probably would not be here
if you had not been an outelt like an
outsider for many years so it worked
let's just say that lack is ingrained in
there you got the story you lived on the
streets you lost everything you got
betrayed your business partner took
everything took your wife took you got
the story in the half okay okay you got
to start telling a new story of the
future right you got to believe in that
future more than you have to believe in
the past so how do you do that you only
believe in the past when you feel the
emotions of the past the only time
you're going to believe in the future is
when you feel the emotions in the future
right okay so in order for us to change
a belief or perception about our s and
our
lives we have to make a decision with
such firm intention that the amplitude
of that decision carries a level of
energy that's greater than the hardwire
programs in your brain and the emotional
conditioning in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we
regulate that old belief if the trauma
created an emotional quoti of six or
seven then your decision to change your
belief's got to be a nine right and you
got to come out of your resting state
and that moment has to Define you you
could say I know exactly where I was the
time and day it was who I was with when
I made my mind up to change right cuz
you created a longterm memory long-term
memories are created from strong emotion
right but the amplitude of that emotion
is greater than the Betrayal Boom the
body starts responding to the mind and
you're actually giving your body a taste
of the future emotionally so you brand
your impossible no your body is actually
getting the taste of that future vent
it's experiencing the future now exactly
big explosion on the quantum field big
explosion so the side effect of that is
if you combine that clear intention with
that elevated emotion you're basically
remembering your future and it looks no
different than remembering your past
think neurologically within the circuits
of that memory and feel within the
emotions of that new belief and watch
your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change and when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lack we in lack of Separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for
us to become abundant we have to
overcome the old personality and that's
95% of who we are right yes so then the
side effect of the beginning of this
process is a lot of discomfort it is a
lot of discomfort because you're
stepping outside the known into the
unknown and now you can't predict scary
no no you you'd rather hold on to your
lack the pain suffering rather tell the
story of that at least it makes you feel
something that's familiar when you step
outside and you're saying I'm not going
to complain about money any longer I'm
not going to complain about I don't have
any I'm not going to judge other people
who do I'm not going to say I can I'm
not worthy it's never going to work all
those things got to go I'm not going to
feel lack I'm not going to feel unworthy
I'm not going to feel separation I'm not
going to feel resentment these are the
things that are keeping my reality the
same now it's no longer about abundance
it's about who you become mhm so the
overcoming process becomes the becoming
process and so many people come through
this work they want abundance they want
healing they want a new relationship
they want a new career they want the
mystical but really they want wholeness
and and they want healing they want
peace they want wholeness cuz they feel
on whole well well when you're in lack
or you're in separation you're not whole
imagine feeling so much wholeness that's
impossible to want that's what our
that's what we're working on with people
then you can really enjoy a sunset then
you can really enjoy a meal then you can
really enjoy your friends then you can I
I I I talk to people that are very
abundant I mean in the billions abundant
and you know so many of them say we are
in
misery we're in agony because they can't
enjoy life anymore that's what they want
I mean people want abundance to be able
to enjoy life they want to be able to do
whatever they want with whoever they
want as many times as they want wherever
they want that's Freedom right we want
abundance the sponsoring thought is
really they want freedom right or
whatever they're sponsoring thought
would be right I know you all have big
goals Big Dreams big aspirations just
like I do you got Ambitions to become an
amazing person to build your career to
create to contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits set up
if you don't have routine and structure
set up in a way that will keep you on
track then you you'll fall off and and
and having new goals without new habits
is kind of like you know having a new
car without wheels you know the habits
are the wheels they're the things that
make you able to achieve the goals so
you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
at the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out more on a more regular basis
and then it goes away or you say you
know I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for 2
or three days and then on the fourth day
you're a jerk you know and you're like
what what happened I said I was going to
be nicer it's that you didn't set up the
most important thing you needed to
maintain a habit so what's the biggest
secret I've learned in almost 20 years
in this field it's so simple but most
people don't have it it's called trigger
moments you have to set up trigger
moments to activate your habits what do
I mean by that well let's say you want
to become a a better person you know you
want to become more kind more patient
more loving with people now you can just
set that intention or write that down in
your vision your journal or set up on a
vision board that you look at once in a
while but in daytoday life it's not
enough you need things to trigger you to
remind you to be that particular kind of
person right it's almost like if you
could have a little angel speaking in
your ear all day long to tell you what
to do and how to be you obviously become
better well that makes sense well let's
use that idea let's use that idea by
setting up alarms on our phones that
trigger us to do the very things we need
to do this is going to be so basic
you're going to laugh and then I'll also
tell you how I've literally taught this
to Fortune 50 CEOs and they said it was
the one thing that changed their life
the most dramatically so let's start
with this let's I have a goal in mind
let's say you want to become more
present and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal I'm going to be more present and
calm you could meditate in the morning
say today I'm going to be more present
and calm and you you could you could
start out with good intentions but those
fall apart without a trigger moment set
up throughout the day to remind you that
so what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label that said close
your
eyes take 10 deep breaths in remind
yourself to be calm so let's say you're
going through through your day it's
crazy right it's 10:00 a.m. and all a
sudden Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at 2:00 and again it happens at 6:00
p.m. and again it happens at 8:00 p.m.
what's going to happen you always look
at your phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that that changed
everything and you'll think once you set
it up that the next day you you'll
you'll forget about it no that alarm
will go off you forgot you set the dang
alarm there it goes off in your face and
you're like all right I'm trying to be
calmer and more present close my eyes
take 10 deep breaths reground myself
here we go you can't do it once a day
you have to have moments throughout the
day that trigger you to enact the new
Behavior I know this makes sense to you
but it's a challenge for a lot of people
CU they never set those things up so
what if you did it with an alarm so for
example for me on the opposite Spectrum
I don't want to just be calmer and more
present I Want More Energy throughout
the day so here's what I do one of my
big trigger moments is every time my
butt hits a chair I don't care if I'm on
a plane or I was like where we're
shooting here I I wrote a lot of my
books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes now at 50
minutes the timer goes it starts buzzing
and I look at that and I go oh that's my
trigger to get energy so I stand up I go
get some water I take a glass of water
drink it down I do some stretches and I
do some exercise just really briefly or
I'll go for a walk whatever it is but
I'll do something that usually takes
just 2 to 5 minutes then I'll sit back
down I'll set that 50-minute alarm and
I'll work and what that does is every 50
minutes it triggers me to change change
how I'm physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that 2 3 4:00 time where I'm like ah you
know why because I've triggered my day
so that my energy is maintained
throughout the day makes sense right
this could be as simple as let's say you
want to be healthier in your life okay
let's set up some trigger moments for
you in this way let's say every time you
drop off the kids on the way back to the
house you stop at the grocery store and
get some fresh produce that's just a
trigger it's like okay did one thing
drop kids off now tied to that triggered
from that action drop kids off is go to
health food store or let's say you want
to get healthier in the morning one of
the easiest ways to help people maintain
a better exercise program is this set a
trigger you wake up in the morning your
first action is to drink water put your
exercise shoes on uh might get dressed
if you were naked just saying so you get
dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
doorframe triggers what do you mean by
that when you walk into a new room to
have a psychological trigger go off in
your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
if I've been working all day and I'm
going to walk in I'm going to see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said the three words
said the three words and I did this so
many times that now when I walk through
a door my mind automatically triggers
those three words and I remember to be
those three words so what words would
you love to have describe you as a
person that you would be happy if that
was how people described you what would
those words be have those and now set
them up in your life I teach Executives
to do this as well I have them have a
doorframe trigger when they walk into
their office in the morning soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
every time they walk into a meeting into
the conference room when they walk
through the doors of the conference room
they have another three words that
trigger off for them and it just reminds
them how to be so these aren't big crazy
things a lot of people they think they
have to completely change their life
what would change your life completely
is setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you uh
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that
you're interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
certain actions take place you do things
you
know they're not
the optimal things to do but you can't
help it it's
something acts through you um there
there seems to be some power there that
makes you do things but you know Noah
not right or not good for you and yet
you can't stop it that seems to be the
case
um and that of course um
is often the case with people who are
with you it might be many different
different areas of your life but uh
um this is also the case with addictions
for example people are addicted to a
certain substance or who are addicted to
eating too much or drinking um there's
something that overpowers them in you
that seems to
obscure the awareness or the awareness
is pushed to to the side and this thing
this this powerful thing does it
anyway and again my answer is a little
bit similar to
um what I said to the first questioner
uh
tonight
the the power of
presence needs to grow in you so
that it is strong enough not to is not
willpower because willpower is not the
best way of dealing with these things
but it's what I'm talking about could
sometimes be confused with willpower but
willpower includes the um application of
a force to hold something down let's say
um
if your addiction is to um have a to
indulge in intoxicating beverages in
other words booze is the British word uh
then uh and you can feel it it's it
comes on there it comes you know the
bottles are there there they are and you
feel you have to go there and you have
to reach out and you have to pour
yourself a drink now when you're not
aware at all you don't even know what
you're doing you're so unconscious that
you you're already holding the drink and
you're drinking then you at that point
you you even know that you're drinking
uh the same with food I've spoken to
people who have had addictions to food
they often say they wake up when they
already they've already eaten in the
middle of the night they've already
unconsciously gone to the fridge taken
out the chocolate cake and then they're
already halfway through the chocolate
cake when way what am I
doing but so awareness comes in at a
very late Point willpower would be to
hold an urge down let say I God they
have the pull or even what the example
you gave you want to turn on the TV and
you know it's not right because I I'm
not here for that and he actually told
us not to do
it and I but I can't help it I have to
go I can't I can't now willpower you
would you would say I'm going to hold
this down I'm not going to do
it and I you can feel the urge but
you're holding it
down um when you hold things
down often after a while the an
explosion happens it's like a boiling
kettle
can't hold it for that long and then you
have some kind of rationalization in
your mind
why you do it anyway the mind will give
you a reason to overcome the
body takes a will that's greater than
the program to to no longer get up and
run through the same routine that you do
every day and your body wants in the
middle of meditation saying quit I'm too
tired you got too many texts you got too
many emails you got too many things to
do the body has been programmed to get
up and go and you and you say wait wait
wait wait wait a second here we're not
going anywhere until I get clear on who
I want to be today and every time you
execute that will that's greater than
the program people say oh I'm I can't
meditate actually you're doing it right
actually that's why it's hard because
doing it you're actually that is the
process right there there's no such
thing as a bad meditation what you're
doing is actually exactly what you need
to do and every time you do that you
become conscious that you go unconscious
that's how you actually develop the
skill of Consciousness it's not being
conscious it's catching yourself when
you go unconscious people if they can
see thinking is the unconscious
essentially conscious is connecting to
everything which is in the space of
nothingness really but there's a journey
to get there and if you're patient with
yourself and you see that as a
victory like oh you start getting
aroused you start getting frustrated you
think I can't do this and you go oh no
no no no no no no we're not going to
quit here that would be me getting up as
the same person I'm curious what's on
the other side of this frustration you
settle your body back down into the
present moment you unfold back into that
Eternal space I'm telling you every time
you do that it's a victory you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind then it actually
turns out that the body starts
liberating energy it starts liberating
energy but like an unbridled stallion it
goes oh really you think that's all you
think that's all you have watch this and
then it gets starts up memories of the
past and all of that just to feel an
emotion and if you're aware that it's
doing that and you settle it down you're
you're taming the animal you're teaching
it you're you're teaching it how to
change its state right and guaranteed if
you keep doing that you walk out in your
life I guarantee you'll be less
responsive and reactionary to everyone
and everything so in seven days we see
that not only there dramatic biological
changes to suggest that the person
environment but it it goes for the
majority of people that immerse
themselves in going all in and what does
that mean a different environment
they're in a ballroom they're in a
ballroom I've been to thousands of
ballrooms there's nothing really
exciting in a ballroom what's exciting
in a ballroom they all look the same but
the data suggests that they're in a
whole new environment where where is
that where is that taking place it's
taking place from within the person
closed eyed internal world is everything
first you see the need to be a victim
identity also unfortunately is a form of
ego because any conceptual identity is a
form of ego and even though you seem to
be amply justified in having a victim
identity because of the things that
other humans did to you you yourself are
finding you are finding yourself in a
kind of
prison that created by your
mind so there's no denial of that bad
things happen to you yes now question is
how do you exit this mental
present the first step is perhaps to
see
um that uh unconscious human
beings unconscious human beings in the
grip of their own conditioning their own
ego they have virtually no free
will when you are
unconscious you are controlled
by the the called Mind patterns that are
lodged in your
psyche you have you cannot really speak
of Free Will by somebody who with zero
awareness and yet the entire make up is
uh conditioning from the
past so the famous sentence phrase used
by Jesus in connection with forgiveness
on the cross he said forgive them for
they know not what they
do now these these two interesting these
points put together forgive them why
forgive them they know not what they do
in other words if he had spoken these
days using our
terminology he probably would have said
they are completely
unconscious because that's what it means
they know not what they do they're
completely
unconscious uh so when you see nobody
can act beyond their level of
Consciousness then you see that it's
almost like it becomes almost like like
the evil that was perpetrated becomes
almost like a natural
phenomenon that is like you've been hit
by lightning or something
or lived in very
unpleasant climatic conditions that that
injured
you near
volcano my dad what what had problems
with anger huge outbursts of anger quite
frequently it was living like living
legs to a volcano that could erupt at
any
moment and he could not help it it was
it was impossible there was no
possibility of being
different and so these
humans are run by unconscious
conditioning usually goes back to their
childhood and what happened
there I know why my father was angry I I
re I realized much later that it all
originated in his childhood the reasons
why he was so angry and
also for a while also I felt a
resentment towards that and only when I
was able to awaken out of egoic
Consciousness I saw that there there's
nothing that he could have done
differently because there wasn't enough
awareness
now when you see that then you
don't personalize or you don't create an
identity for other humans out of their
unconsciousness because in essence
that's not who they are the recognition
that there's first recognition then step
one you recognize that no human can act
beyond their
conditioning in the absence of
awareness if there's awareness they can
transcend their conditioning and then
they begin to become conscious of their
own conditioned mental emotional
dysfunctional mental emotional patterns
yes so they couldn't they can't help it
so that's that's already a useful step
in forgiveness but it you may not yet be
able to arrive at at full forgiveness
because of that another before I
continue with that does that mean then a
question may arise in your mind does
that mean then humans are not really
responsible for what they
do if they're unconscious how are they
respons and does that mean then that we
shouldn't punish them for what they do
if they commit a
crime are they not
guilty that's an interesting
question
the the
unconsciousness that operates in human
even if you are able to forgive a human
and we come we'll go more fully into
that in a minute even if you're able to
forgive an human for their
transgressions or whatever they
did uh this does not mean and even
though the human is not responsible for
their unconsciousness and
yet it is built into the structure of
human
life they still need to suffer the
consequences of their
unconsciousness I think there are many
modalities that work for trauma what
I've discovered is that Insight never
really changes Behavior you can see that
your father was overbearing or was an
alcoholic or you could see all these
different things you know like you could
come up with the insight all these
different things the problem that I see
with people is then they tend to excuse
their
change by saying oh I had a rough
childhood that's why I am the way I am
they're excusing their pre present
position so and again trauma is a
difficult thing but for
me the person who's living by the
identity in their life that they were
traumatized as a child or whatever it is
or they've had a trauma in their life
not saying forget the trauma and create
another emotion I'm saying that the
person who's willing to go through the
emotion and keep working on lowering the
volume to it they the we have had so
many people in this work with brutal
pasts really really difficult pasts do
the work and finally they reach that
point where they just break free from
the emotion they look back and I have
interviewed enough of them it's the same
thing they look back at their entire
past and they don't want to change one
thing in their past cuz it brought them
to this elegant moment where they're
liberated they see their betrayers they
see their abusers they have nothing but
love for them now the side effect of
that and many times they'll say it was
like my heart blew wide open they had to
pass through the valley of the shadow of
Darkness to get there they just thought
I I don't know if I can go any further
and they went one more
time and the body literally was
liberated from the past right cuz the
trauma is not just in the brain the
trauma stored emotionally in the body so
you want to take the body out of the
past out of the known what do you think
the body is going to say if it's been
conditioned to be the mind the unknown
is a scary place you step out into the
unknown you're going to be unprepared
for that trauma you don't know how it's
going to happen and so the person keeps
clinging to the known and but when the
person finally overcomes the emotion the
body literally is freed from the chains
of the past the side effect of that is
seeing the paast from a greater level of
Consciousness lo and
behold there goes the Suicidal
Tendencies there goes the dysfunction
there goes the irritable bowel syndrome
that's was because the body was still
living in that past event by living by
the same emotion so the research on
memory is kind of fascinating and I just
I've studied it enough and and
and the way we recount the past is not
the way it happened even if you
absolutely think you remember it being
that way so we don't have the same brain
as we did when we were 8 years old or 12
years old or 20 years old we have a
different brain we have a completely
different brain so the fabrication of
the story for many people they embellish
the story and make it seem even worse
than what it was but you're really what
you're saying is I changed in those
moments and from a biological standpoint
I haven't been able to change since so
let me tell you why it's been so hard
for me to change and the story becomes
dramatized or
embellished the person Works them up
fire themselves into this emotional
froth and then fires and wires the same
circuits in the brain and they're
actually reaffirming their limitation
now there's nothing wrong with that I
think we're just taking too long right
so 50% of that story isn't even the
truth it means in a sense we're reliving
a miserable life that we never even had
and we don't want but but the but the
the unknown people would rather cling to
their
suffering this is not a judgment we all
do this we'd rather stay in the known
than take a chance in the unknown
because those emotions of survival are
saying what run from the unknown the
unknown is a scary place so now the the
unknown you got to come up against that
moment where you're going to actually
leave that behind and step into the
unknown this is not a intellectual
process this is this is David and
Goliath there's a battle going on where
the body keeps wanting to go back to its
familiar State cuz it's subconsciously
been conditioned to be the Mind stay in
the known if you think money is scarce
you hoard it because you believe that no
more money will come to you if you know
money is abundant more money will flow
to you this isn't about being wasteful
doesn't doesn't mean you have to go and
always empty your pockets and buy a lot
of dumb stuff and throw away all your
other stuff it doesn't mean you have to
waste your
money but it's switching the mindset of
money is not just some scarce thing that
you don't know how to make that you will
never have more of and so you need to
hoard every single dollar that you've
got this is honestly something that I am
continuing to rewire myself on I
struggled a lot with money especially in
the early days of my business
um even growing up I I grew up in a
middle class family my parents spent my
parents are behind me on the wall hold
on there we go this is me when I'm eight
or nine and my parents here they
believed in education a lot and they
didn't have a ton of money we weren't
poor but they spent all of their money
basically on putting the three of us
kids that have two sisters through
private school so any money that they
made basically poured into our education
and as a result we didn't have you know
money for other things and um where my
friends at these fancy schools were
getting you know BMWs for their 16th
birthday so they can go off and drive uh
you know I didn't get any of that and
it's not wo was me but it's more I just
had a scarce mentality around money in
my first business I was making 300 bucks
a month I was eating the same bean salad
lunch every day because it would fill me
up and wasn't uh very expensive when we
celebrated a wi we'd go to McDonald's if
we got a new client like hey we sold
another piece of our software we go to
McDonald's and order a large fries and
share that between the three of us cuz
it was cheap and we wanted just some
little way to celebrate
and I just remember how painful it was
to feel like you have no money and you
can't buy stuff and I couldn't hang out
with my friends and I couldn't do what I
wanted to do and I think that has a
traumatic effect you know I mean maybe
that's you as well you you have a
scarcity mindset around money that you
don't know how to make it and so
anything you've got you got to really
hold on to it and protect it and again
I'm not advocating for being Reckless or
stupid or just throwing money away be be
smart about how you're going to invest
and use your money the more important
thing is developing the mindset that you
can create money that by bringing a lot
of value to people you can make more
money you can turn it into something so
one of the things that I've done
recently that that um has helped both
myself and Nina my wife is we create
what we call a care fund and every month
when we're doing our numbers uh Nina
will put together how much we've made
this month how much cashs come in ETC
and then we allocate a certain
percentage for a care fund that we have
to go off and
spend uh either for ourselves or for
other people and so my default is to
invest invest invest invest invest right
like invest back in the business invest
into into into markets invest into
assets just invest invest invest invest
invest
invest the and that's a that's a great
good mindset the downside of that is you
don't get to see the impact that it can
create and so said you know what we need
to dedicate a percentage every month to
go and help somebody else and maybe it's
help ourselves you know um on the
weekend Nina bought a uh very very
expensive
purse we went shopping she bought a very
expensive purse we bought a Chanel bag
and probably more expensive than she's
ever bought a bag and for me it's like
oh my gosh she can't be spending this
amount of money on a
bag but it's worth celebrating yourself
like you know what like we earned that
we did so much work in our business you
can you can go and afford that we've
also used the money to donate the ch
ities we've also used the money to uh
support our family and things that they
needed or wanted in their lives and it's
something that we have to spend every
month Nina asked hey can we just save it
so we can invest more and then that
leads to more in the future like no
we're already saving other money to do
that like that has to be spent every
month and so where we have to sit this
might sound crazy we have to sit down
every month and figure out how are we
going to spend this money because my
default is not to go and spend the
default is to invest or just to
save and so doing that it doesn't have
to be a big amount of money it could it
could be a hundred bucks a month that
you force yourself to spend on making
somebody else's life better or even your
own like that thing that you would never
buy for yourself you know what I've
worked hard like I'm going to buy it or
you're going to go buy somebody a meal
or you're going to go and give a
homeless person $100 right like you're
going to you're going to do something
with it because what it does it starts
to change your mentality around it it
starts to make you feel
like more will come that I'm
creating and so whether it's 10 bucks
100 bucks 1,000 bucks 10,000 bucks like
you know whatever it is I'm not
advocating you go drain your bank
account and just go crazy and buy a
Chanel bag you know but allocating
certain percentage every
month so that you can start to rewire
your belief
around money that it's not just super
scarce so that would be step number one
right allocate some kind of budget to
helping especially others cuz when you
can when you help others it just makes
you feel so good and you can help others
in a lot of ways you can help them with
your time you can help them with your
expertise you can help them you know not
just give a man a fish but teach them
how to fish right but there's there's
the immediate gratification of helping
somebody buying the coffee for the
person behind you in line or seeing
somebody that you know that that 25
bucks 100 bucks make a big difference
and like you were able to afford to do
that gives you the extra oomph to go off
and want to do more of it like if you
know that that 25 bucks change that
person's life imagine if you can give
them 2500 bucks but to do that you'd
have to go off and build a bigger
business right so the the core of your
business needs to be serving and helping
and contributing back and you can't
afford yet to give somebody 2500 bucks
which you could if you kept building
your business and so just gives that
little extra bit of motivation and
incentive right to get out there and
start to do it to allocate a certain
percentage second is to be around people
who are who are generous be around the
people who have the mindset that you
want to have if there's a belief that
you want to adopt the fastest way to do
it is to be around the people who
constantly are screaming that belief the
people who are constantly living that
belief so if you love my view on
something great hang around me more
often there's lots of videos love Grant
cardone's view or Gary Vee's view or
Oprah's view on something the more you
hang around them and watch their content
and read their books and listen to their
speeches the more you're going to start
to adopt that same belief
system so if you want to believe that
money is not scarce then you need to be
hanging around people who believe that
money is not scarce because probably the
people in your life believe money is
really scarce and the people that I grew
up with believe that money is really
scarce the closest people around me and
so it doesn't mean you stop hanging out
with them but you need to inject new
people in even if it's just through
YouTube videos of the people who believe
the thing that you want to believe cuz
otherwise you get pulled back down CU
your environment has been created to
keep you where you are so if you want to
change where you are you have to change
the environment and it used to be that
you had to you have to really change you
had to go somewhere else you had to move
out you had to find a mentor to hang out
with and have coffee with consistently
now you can do it through through
YouTube I've been inspired by tons of
mentors who have never
met because of the content that I've
learned from them on YouTube but it
takes the effort and intention to be
consistently around it that this is the
belief system that you want to have you
need to create that habit for yourself
from the things that are on the wall to
the clothes that you wear to the the
media that you're consuming every day
being intentional with that to say this
is this this is the belief system that I
want to have I recognize I'm not there
yet but this is this belief system I
want to have and I want to be around the
people who believe this to their core
because their belief in that thing is
stronger than your belief against it and
whoever is more confident wins and so
when you're around the people who
believe that thing so much they will
pull you towards them to start having
that similar belief system and then
everything starts to change I think
having a scarcity mindset is extremely
limiting I've I've lived through really
intense versions of it I still feel like
I'm coming out of it I've grown a lot
compared to where I used to be but still
have a lot a long ways to go I probably
still have
things that I'm holding on to that I
shouldn't uh I probably still should be
more generous than I am um and I'm I'm
working through it as well I might just
be a little bit further ahead on the
curve definitely compared to 19-year-old
Evan who thought money was the most
scarce thing in the world when you can
learn to make that rewiring happen
that's how you start to change your life
so if you look at the people around you
look at their beliefs especially around
money and see what do they think and
then see where they're at in their life
compared to the people who have
different beliefs around money and where
they're at who would you rather be and
you could be there you could be that
person if you start to change your
beliefs your environment start to help
more people with it start to allow the
money to flow because when you start to
believe that you can create a lot more
money for yourself a lot of things start
to change because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
to learn how to use positive language to
get what you want check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there when I say watch your language our
words shape the way we think and how we
feel and how we feel determines what we
do and what we do determines whether we
get results or not I'm talking about
being aware that there are certain words